I don't know why you're not in the fight
nights I don't know why you haven't done
a pay-per-view yet it just it doesn't
make sense to me
well it would be so refreshing it's like
we're just going to keep doing the same
thing over and over when you have the
chops to do it there are I mean it's a
it's as with anything in a company like
this there are there's a multi-layered
reason for why that hasn't happened yet
for sure and I'm sure I don't know many
of the layers you don't have to worry
about Let Me Be frustrated about it if I
was your manager I'd be super frustrated
but you don't need to work you're just
going to keep doing what you're doing
and I guarantee it happens I I am
manifesting it daily let me tell you